do you think that you are underrated as
a guitar player I didn't even realize on
on the track Woodstock that you put out
with the Crosby Stills Nash and Young
when you put that out that was you on
that lead you're the guy playing that
iconic riff right on Woodstock
yeah I think the beginning Rift down and
down this thing yeah that's you yeah
that's some good guitar work right
come with an accident
you can see I started before everybody
else
you jumped in first I was there yeah we
had one time that was a good one when
you hear that riff now are you moved by
it I mean do you go man that's a [ __ ]
that gives me the chills that riff every
time I hear it I I like it I like it you
got our shirt Stills original vocal it
was amazing see we were just hung up on
making everything perfect so we all
thought we had to do it again
but we didn't I mean he's his overdub
vocal is great I mean it's the one
everybody hears and it's a great vocal
but the original vocal
was funky to like the guitar is funky
okay wow
is that what pissed you off about being
in band sometimes that you would have
just left his vocal the way it was but
you can't convince the rest of the band
to do it
never even got to that point you know we
just it just it was going so fast uh
we finished the record and I didn't
realize till later on but when I heard
the original vocal again oh we screwed
up
we were trying to be good we tried
big bummer never should have done that
if you try too hard you can lose the
essence of Music in other words if you
try at all
you shouldn't try
I think you should just let it be
then you got the essence of what it is
if you're trying you're trying to do
something that you think you should be
doing you've lost it already
what it is is what you do you know you
don't I don't I it's what comes
naturally the first time
foreign